all peaceful in the oxfordshire village
of shrivernam
but just down the road a hostile state
like china or russia may have been
behind a secret cyber attack against
part of the uk's ministry of defense
the target was this place the defense
academy where officers rising up through
the ranks come to learn both offline and
online the then director general has
agreed to speak for the first time about
the hack those contractors that first
spotted you know back in march some
unusual activity over a weekend
and then pretty quickly realized that
there were
external agents
on our network who looked like they were
there for
what looked pretty quickly like
nefarious reasons the alarm bells rang
and at that point we start to really
dive in and see what's going on
he's not sure who was to blame but
suspects criminals or a foreign power
operating in a gray zone of harm under
the threshold of war
the academy's i.t system perhaps seen as
a back door to try and penetrate wider
defense networks to steal secrets
why would we not expect therefore to be
conducting gray zone operations just
because
we're an educational establishment
outside swindon
yeah there's an example of how the front
line is
has changed and is changing and what was
the consequence of all of this
consecutive operations were
significant but they're manageable but
only manageable because your people work
incredibly hard to keep things going and
and find backup methodologies
no big secrets were swiped but for
teachers and students it's been harder
to access online material and emails as
the academy's entire network is being
rebuilt and made more resilient
it's been almost a year since the cyber
attack on the defense academy was first
discovered but the ministry of defense
has yet to say anything publicly about
who it thinks was responsible asked for
a comment a spokesperson said swift
action was taken to deal with the
incident and there was no impact on the
wider ministry of defense it network
but there are calls for greater openness
when it comes to suspected gray zone
attacks
there's a clear public interest in the
mod letting more be known about the
patterns of activity that are targeting
this country and trying to damage and
degrade it and we think that there's no
real reason why we shouldn't know more
about what our servicemen and women have
to face on a daily basis
for now with the cyber hack only the
defense academy's website offers a clue
something was amiss
debra haynes sky news